Exaspérée, nous dit c'était
citoyenne. Bonsoir à vous :
- bonsoir.
- Vous avez de l'expérience.
Pourquoi c'est si long?
- C'est compliqué parce que
c'est de la responsabilité de
chacun des arrondissements de la
ville de Montréal s'est fusionné
chaque arrondissement est
responsable de son développement
économique. Cependant il y a des
façons de faire. Il y a des
choses qu'on doit jamais
oublier, c'est que
l'arrondissement est au service
de sa population. Ce n'est pas
la population qui est au service
des autres. On est là pour
rendre des services. Quand les
gens veulent construire, c'est
la vache à lait de
l'arrondissement. Les produits
et les revenus des permis reste
à l'arrondissement. Il y a des
arrondissements qui n'ont pas
trop compris cela. Chez nous,
quand on est arrivé et que la
mise en place, on s'est dit :
quand quelqu'un vient nous voir
et qu'on peut émettre le permis
le plus rapidement possible
parce que ça respecte les
règles, on les passe en 24
heures pas de problème. Quand il
y en a qui doive passer au
comité consultatif d'urbanisme,
ce n'est pas dans deux semaines
à attendre. On dit parfois en
regard de votre dossier et le
prochain, on vous mêla.
- Les CCU c'est pour les gros
affaires.
- C'est pour ceux qui ne peuvent
pas l'avoir en 24 heures parce
que ça doit respecter le
règlement. Ça peut prendre un
mois ou deux mois. C'est le plus
gros. Il y a des méga gros au
centre-ville c'est autre chose.
De façon générale, les
historiens n'ont pas à attendre
autant longtemps pour des
dossiers comme cela.
Il faut vraiment que les élus
les nouveaux qui s'en viennent
soient aussi conscients de cela.
Les patrons, ce sont les
citoyens. Les fonctionnaires et
les élus sont au service des
citoyens. C'est un service qu'on
offre. Ceux qui veulent vraiment
bien gérer c'est de l'argent qui
rentre pas
- Luc, vous avez connu ça aussi.
Au plateau, ça s'est dégradé par
rapport à autrefois. Peu
importe. Comment ça se fait?
C'est le manque de personnel?
- Plusieurs choses. Trois types
d'intervention. Intervention
d'intérieur ça prend permis mais
c'est un permis pour être
conforme au code de la
construction. Quand la designer
disait qu'on pouvait avoir pas
de permis, c'est moins grave à
l'intérieur. L'ancienne
intervention à l'extérieur...
- même qu'on est obligé d'en
avoir un, dans les pas en
chercher un?
- Ce n'est pas ça. Une
intervention d'intérieur
nécessite beaucoup moins de
travail. On va juste gronder si
c'est conforme au code de
construction. C'est long à cause
du personnel. Le prix de la
demande. Les travaux qui
nécessitent des changements
architecturaux ou des
démolitions, il faut que ce soit
trois lectures au conseil et ça
passe en CCU comme le disait
Annie. C'est une bonne chose
parce que des maisons qui sont
construites qui ont fait de
l'ombre sur le seul espace
habitable du voisin ou qui ont
été obligé de couper les arbres
auxquels on fait plus haut que
le code de construction, ça plus
dans les arrondissements. Ça
prend un permis pour tout
agrandissement. C'est exigible.
Il faut avoir le personnel et
les états d'intervention sont
longues. Je recommande vraiment
pas à la dame qui disait : je
pense y aller sans permis.
Des énormes contraventions et
des arrêts de chantier. Elle va
perdre son entrepreneur.
- Vous la comprenez d'être
excédé.
- Bien sûr.
Le poste d'agent qui reçoit les
demandes de permis, c'est un
poste d'entrée à la ville. Les
architectes veux pas faire ça.
Dès qu'ils ont de l'expérience
ils vont ailleurs. C'est
difficile d'en recruter. Il y a
eu un gel de toutes les dépenses
en interne...
- est-ce qu'on peut simplifier
le processus un peu?
Est-ce qu'on peut simplifier?
C'est compliqué.
- C'est une façon d'organiser le
travail et c'est faisable. Parce
que c'est totalement illogique
de faire attendre des familles
cette mention veut qu'il reste à
Montréal. C'est illogique.
- C'est très possible de le
faire pour les portes et les
fenêtres. L'intérieur des
maisons aussi. La plus grosse
intervention c'est plus
difficile.
- Annonce du jour : Mme Plante
de faire de Montréal une ville
de la nordicit.é elle rendrait
l'hiver joyeux. Elle veut dans
les parcs envoyés de la neige
pour qu'on puisse glisser parce
qu'on sait qu'il manque de
neige.
- De toutes petites
interventions comme la piste de
ski de fond qui était mise dans
le parc Lafontaine ont un effet
spectaculaire. Il faut faire des
petites interventions comme
cela. Il ne faut pas oublier que
notre hiver, maintenant on avait
un cycle de gel et dégel. Cela
coûte très cher. Elles doivent
être modestes les intervention.
- Je trouve cela important. On
sait que depuis la pandémie les
gens sont habitués de sortir
prendre leur marge. Dans le parc
Jarry, il y a une piste de ski
de fond à la demande des
citoyens. C'est adoré. C'est
important mais ce que j'ai aimé
du projet, les terrasses. Les
terrasses où on va enfin pouvoir
permettre les réchauds, parce
que ce n'est pas permis
actuellement. Ça permettrait..
- c'est obscur.
Parlons du projet de M. Coderre
dans l'est de Montréal. Il dit
qu'il faut revoir il propose de
faire plus de station du REM.
- À l'est, je n'en reviens pas
et je comprends pas pourquoi on
s'obstine à faire uniquement de
l'industriel. Le coût s'est
énorme.
Je pense que si on veut vraiment
transformer l'est, il faut
beaucoup penser au résidentiel.
- Je pense que la mixité est
importante. On disait qu'on
voulait faire plus d'espaces
verts là-bas et que ce soit plus
sur le plan environnemental
accessible. Il y a des
compagnies actuellement, ça crée
des emplois à Montréal. Ça
rapporte beaucoup de taxes
aussi. Il faut aussi le verdir.
C'est de bon augure le fait que
le REM sera là. Il aura des
impacts sur l'économie.
- Est-ce que vous sentez que la
campagne s'accélère?
- Oui. Avec les annonça tous les
jours, il y en a plein.
C'est Noël tous les jours. C'est
intéressant. J'ai hâte qu'on
puisse voir le bilan de financer
combien ça va coûter toutes les
promesses.
- Rien à ajouter. C'est vrai que
une demande par jour, une
demande par jour, c'est ce qui a
fait la popularité de Mme Plante
à notre élection. Ça donne un
bon match.
- Parlons des matchs. Lundi
prochain, sur nos ondes, une
heure, un face-à-face entre
Denis Coderre et Valérie Plante.
Les deux principaux candidats
seuls avec quelques questions
des citoyens préenregistrés.
Leur à nos questions et les
rassure tous les débats le plus
libre possible. 18 heures à
Radio-Canada et